permanent nous a gâtés cette année bien
sûr comme chaque année j'ai eu des
chocolats j'ai eu des bijoux j'ai eu des
parfums et j'ai eu de l'argent très
généreux beaucoup de cadeaux est très
sympa et il va encore passer je pense
mais il m'a déjà datés par mes filles
chaque année après noël deux camps
s'affrontent celles et ceux qui sont
satisfaits de leurs cadeaux et les
autres moi je suis pas du tout tubes des
années 80 donc ça me direz c'est pas du
tout j'ai eu ça j'ai eu plein de choses
comme ça a fait des choses voilà des
livres du foie bons qui sont pas que
j'aime pas moi je préfère me faire mes
cadeaux moi même mais pelé aulas pour
les déçus de noël une solution la
revente sur des sites internet ou encore
dans des enseignes spécialisés dans
l'achat vente dans cette boutique de
montigny le bretonneux les revente
d'objets augmente de 30% pendant cette
période principalement des doublons ou
alors ils ont vendu alors ils ont
anticipé
ils ont vendu leur téléphone avant noël
savent qu'ils vont recevoir de l'argent
le 25 et vont venir
aussi acheté un téléphone nouvelle
génération les jeux vidéo ou les
consoles font également partie des
articles les plus revendus selon un
sondage paru cette année 34 % des
français se disent prêts à revendre
leurs cadeaux
les gens sont de plus en plus ouverts à
revendre leurs cadeaux qu'on n'a plus en
fait cette honte d'aller acheter aux
ventes de l'occasion maintenant c'est
c'est très clairement rentrés dans les
moeurs la tendance ces dernières années
à l'économie circulaire pouces est
également de plus en plus de français à
se séparer de leurs cadeaux inutiles